Speaking of going forward to the election,
we actually have some what I think is overall
very good news and news that is extremely
triggering for the president of the United
States, Donald Trump.
The second and final presidential debate is
this Thursday, and candidate microphones will
be muted during the initial answer periods
when the other candidate is speaking.
This is not going to apply during the open
discussion period.
You're still going to have back and forth
during the open discussion.
But as you might remember, during the first
presidential debate, Donald Trump just would
not stop talking, interrupting Joe Biden.
It wasn't clear whether Trump was sort of
manically out bursting or whether it was a
strategy to try to throw Biden off or a combination
of the two.
But it made the debate worthless in terms
of hearing policy ideas, although it does
seem to have hurt Donald Trump in polling
because of his childish, petulant behavior.
So when the we then after that first debate
had the Commission on Presidential Debates
announce that what should have been the second
debate would happen be a video conference
because Trump had coronavirus and Trump said
not going to do it remote.
They can silence you whenever they want.
If you do that and he backed out of the debate
altogether.
So we now have one debate to go.
The last debate scheduled for Thursday night
and indeed, during the initial two minute
answer periods, the microphone of the candidate
not speaking will be muted.
The Commission on Presidential Debates said
in a statement that, quote, We realize after
discussions with both campaigns that neither
campaign may be totally satisfied with the
measures announced today.
One may think they go too far and one may
think they do not go far enough.
We are comfortable that these actions strike
the right strike, the right balance, and that
they are in the interest of the American people
for whom these.
Debates are held.
Now, there were some people who soon after
the first debate and people started calling
for the muting of microphones, said a few
mute the mikes.
It's not really a debate.
Few mute mikes.
It's sequential talking points.
It eliminates debate.
It eliminates the possibility of a back and
forth.
This is a balanced approach in the sense that
of each fifteen minute block, four minutes
will be reserved exclusively for one candidate
or the other.
After the four minute period, two minutes,
two minutes for each candidate, then the microphones
are open.
It's open discussion.
So I think it will undeniably make the debate
more watchable.
There are people wondering whether it's really
even better for Biden.
One would imagine that letting Biden kind
of lay out his ideas uninterrupted will help
him.
And I think it would.
The counter is, does it help him more than
the damage Trump does by just talking over
Biden during those initial couple of minutes?
Biden could have helped himself by speaking
uninterrupted.
But Trump really cratered in the polls after
that first debate.
In the end, again, there will be time for
both.
Four of each fifteen minutes will be including
Mike muting.
So it's a relatively small adjustment.
Bottom line, these are the updated rules and
Donald Trump is already not pleased.
He said yesterday to reporters after being
told about this change, I'll participate.
I just think it's very unfair.
Trump also spent time at a rally in Prescott,
Arizona, yesterday attacking the moderator
of this week's debate.
Who is Kristen Welker?
Take a listen to that.
The real great one.
Another great one.
Kristen Welker.
She's a radical Democrat.
Look at him getting angry.
She deleted her entire account.
Everything is deleted.
But I've known her.
She's been screaming questions at me for a
long time, and she's so good.
So Trump attacking the moderator there.
And then reportedly the president is also
not happy that, as he sees it, the topics
were changed.
Trump kept saying the debate Thursday night
was on foreign policy.
And now, for example, Corona virus is a topic
I always thought that foreign policy was not
the subject of Thursday night's debate.
But Trump is angry, claiming they changed
the topics on him.
So bottom line, I think there's a chance Trump
does back out.
I would put it probably at about 20 percent.
I hope he doesn't.
I hope this debate does happen.
But it's very funny how for months Donald
Trump had been saying, oh, Biden's going to
find a way out.
Biden's brain's not working.
He can't handle debating me.
And then it's Trump who bailed on debate number
two.
And it's Trump who's not pleased with the
guidelines for debate number three.
Now, a serious question and a lot of people
are asking about this.
Is Trump going to just try to interrupt anyway,
even if he's off, Mike?
My guess is if Trump tried to do it, yeah,
it would look very bad.
But you would be able to probably hear Donald
Trump's voice if he tries to interrupt.
Interrupt.
Joe Biden picked up both by Joe Biden's microphone,
maybe as much as by the moderator's microphone.
So I think it's something Trump could do.
I think if he does it, it would look very,
very bad.
And reports are that Trump's advisers and
people prepping him for the debate have been
advising him not to interrupt and to sort
of try to be more likable, even if Trump likes
the idea of being more liked, as I'm sure
his ego would, would like.
Donald Trump has a very hard time controlling
himself, and Donald Trump has a very hard
time listening to people who give him advice
because he thinks he knows better than everybody.
So my prediction is that in Nashville, 9:00
p.m. Eastern on Thursday night, which is when
the debate starts.
My prediction is that Trump's behavior will
be very similar to what we saw in debate number
one at the beginning.
He might be more under control.
I think he will eventually lose it.
I hope you will watch the debate with me.
I will be streaming live on YouTube, Twitter
and Facebook, starting maybe 30, 45 minutes
before the debate.
Join me then and we will take it all in together.
If you're not going to watch the debate, I'm
curious about why.
Let me know on Twitter where you can find
me at də pacman
The
David Pakman Show at David Pakman dot com.